how is the mcu's most cataclysmic event
seen by the reclusive underwater Nation
introduced in Black Panther wakanda
forever or will we never find out keep
watching to learn why some on the
internet are confused
the blip was a huge event for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with a single snap
Thanos eliminated half of the light from
the universe at the end of Avengers
Infinity War only for The Avengers to
bring all the dead back after a
five-year absence and Avengers end game
the Disney plus series The Falcon and
the Winter Soldier dove headfirst into
the finer points of the blip featuring a
terrorist group called the flag Smashers
led by Carly Morgantown they represented
the people who did not die in the blip
yet found themselves in crisis with the
Dead returning to reclaim their old
lives in an interview for Marvel's the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier collector
special Aaron kellyman described what it
was like to make Morgan thou into less
of a clear-cut villain due to her
representing the displaced people after
the events of the blip kellyman
explained even though everything that
she's doing is from a good place her
actions don't really follow that she
begins trying to create change with more
force and starts to deteriorate a little
bit so it was quite interesting to play
that switch in her where she's like okay
I'm gonna leave a mark this is my legacy
rather than the character just having a
Robin Hood kind of vibe you know so even
though Morgan thou does evil things
there your motivations are less strictly
immoral than in the comics as there is
something to be said for her cause
despite the blip being a major event in
the MCU that takes place over the course
of five years in the new movie Black
Panther wakanda forever the famous event
doesn't really come up even when it
should in Black Panther wakanda forever
the wakandans make contact with the
people of talocon an underwater nation
that is the source of vibranium just
like wakanda led by Namor the people of
talocon seek to wage war over one death
leaving some to wonder about what
happened when half of namor's people got
blipped and why that didn't lead to
talocon revealing itself to the outside
world as one redditor pointed out if
Neymar is ready to go to war over one
person dying what does he think happened
during the blip even if he was one of
the people blipped did he just not
believe everyone claiming that they
disappeared for five years there are
ways to explain away the discrepancy but
as some pointed out the fact that no
explanation was offered is their biggest
problem with the situation another
Reddit user brought up a trend in the
last few Marvel projects of moving away
from acknowledging the blip and the
problems that it creates for the overall
plot which the user saw as a positive
but saw some problems with the user
argued here's the problem though agreed
that as a viewer I don't want the blip
to dominate every piece of media but
they chose to write in a seismic event
that warrants it so it feels very
inconsistent that half the world
Vanishing and then returning has been
resolved in only a few years if even
it's true that a whole new civilization
being introduced would seem to Warrant
an explanation about what happened to
them during this universe-wide crisis
but does the Reddit user have a point
about the MCU moving away from the flip
there have been at least in some
projects conscious efforts to avoid
mentions of the blip in an interview
with Lifehacker She-Hulk attorney at law
head writer Jessica GAO said that her
show specifically made a choice to
ignore the landmark event GAO explained
so many shows and movies in the MCU have
already kind of covered that and you
know it's been talked about a lot that
it just feels like okay so many people
have already covered that territory that
we've accepted it we live in a world
where that's already happened and people
have already moved on the verge argued
that Spider-Man far from home one of the
first movies to come out after Avengers
end game succeeded largely because it
ignored the blip it didn't fit into the
rom-com tone in the movie largely making
the blip the butt of a joke as The Verge
pointed out in shorts every single
person on the planet should be brutally
disoriented and traumatized the basic
institutions of society would be thrown
into chaos governments would fall new
religions would spring up Earth would be
unrecognizable while this did get
touched on in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier Marvel was careful to keep that
compartmentalized without any of the
consequences of the blip spilling over
into something as lighthearted as
Spider-Man far from home so it would
seem except in instances where Marvel
specifically wants to address the blip
for plot purposes they're mostly okay
with ignoring it
[Music]